thank you richard for the opportunity
to be here it's been a long time since i
last visited stanford
i think my last visit was academic visit
when i was a physicist probably 10 years
ago
and it's a great honor to be in your
program so what i'm going to do today is
to share with you some of the
insights that we have obtained during
our sort of day-to-day business in asia
and especially i wanted to highlight
china
and since i'm
primarily tracking nanotechnology
together with my team
and so i wanted to put this two together
i guess you know i thought you know nano
is very sexy china's very sexy put it
together
it's it's a good topic um and also like
richard mentioned earlier
china has been
viewed as a place to do chip
manufacturing all these years i mean low
cost a lot of the u.s companies
multinational companies move their
manufacturing to china and in fact you
know companies like ge and dao they
actually set up r d
labs there now
because the the market is there
but what we found in the last
few years especially when we tracked the
nanotechnology r d and commercialization
we find that china is not only
doing low end manufacturing but they're
going to move up they're moving up the
value chain and it's going to take over
the value chain for a lot of the
manufacturing
in
in the world so
well this is a projection whether or not
there will be other competing economy to
to compete with china that's another
question but i wanted to share with you
some of the insights and um
in this opportunity in this
seminar today so how many of you are
familiar with nanotechnology
so maybe okay just to give you a intro a
few seconds 30 seconds of introduction
of what nano scale is
i borrowed the video from
professor checkmark in northwestern
university i thought this is one of one
of my favorite videos about nanoscale so
i i just wanted to share with you now
and
see if you like
oh we didn't plug the sound in
there's so much shrinking and not even
closer
tell you what why don't we run this from
the beginning again
can you run it from the beginning again
now that the to get it on the the sound
off okay you didn't get it oh okay
you keep saying you're building things
this is a meter
this is a centimeter
even after so much shrinking and not
even close to the nano scale
five more times
seven more times
so there you go nanometer is not so
mysterious it's in your your body
already
now then what is nanotechnology i think
there's the definition of nanotechnology
you can find it in textbooks the way i
see it is really the ability
to manipulate atoms and molecules
to make things
with the properties that you desire
and and it's really
at the end of the day it is about
reducing carbon footprint is about lower
cost it's about sustainability so the
way the reason why i love nanotechnology
i've been doing this for the last
morning a decade for 15 years um and and
i just see all the benefits are coming
in a lot of products now you're enjoying
today i mean just
look at your cell phone i'm actually
starting a module in singapore national
university on nanotechnology starting
with the smartphone and beyond
so i will break
take apart your cell phone with myself
oh i don't have a cell phone
look at your galaxy okay i don't i know
you like iphone but it's a little bit
galaxy has more advanced technology if
you have a galaxy
you you're just you're stuck from the
touch screen
okay eventually that touchscreen will be
flexible anyway and more sensitive you
need nano technology for that and
transparent um
and your display now is oled
an oled as you can see it has better
resolution
and
it costs it has less energy consumption
and you go in further and you have the
processor the memory chips is all in
nano scale now otherwise you wouldn't be
able to store so many music so many
files in your in your um
smartphone and and of course the
processor is getting faster and faster
and then you go further down you go
the batteries or you like to charge your
bed you this ideally you want to charge
your battery in 10 minutes rather than
an hour
right if you add nano materials to
electrical materials for lithium-ion
battery you can do that and of course
you also desire your battery will last
more than a day
maybe a week so without charging and and
watch movies without you know charging
it very
soon so you need
high energy
density of your battery so you need nano
materials um and
and and so on and anything that you
could and of course the gyro all the
sensors that you have you know now all
the displays go with you as you flip and
those mems sensors
that uh nano technology make by nano
technology so just look at the
smartphone there's a lot already you use
every day you enjoy the benefit every
day and you want it to have more
benefits from that and in future will be
wearable obviously now the trend is
wearable electronics it's emerging and
it's not far very very soon if you look
at that photo on the
right hand side
that's already not not flexible yet but
bendable displays
that's actually one of the samsung's the
next generation phone
um and then of course the
oled lighting is going to be
in your classroom very soon and in fact
i wouldn't if i'm an investor i wouldn't
even invest in
led anymore because oled is coming and
all this
lighting that you see will be replaced
by just plain lighting 2d rather than
you know led spotlight so you need you
need a lot of lights to to light up this
room but um oled is much more efficient
um and and of course sporting goods
sporting goods that you
in in california i think you do a lot of
sports you want to do bicycle
you do mountain bikes and you need very
strong bikes and you need nano composite
nowadays made of um
bikes are made of nano composites et
cetera so there are a lot of
areas industries and nano technology can
play a role including of course what i
just mentioned
electronic industry consumer electronic
industry displays including displays
energy
including solar cells
batteries
electrical electrical vehicles and
transportation aeroplanes and
and boats i'll show you a video about
you know
a boat that actually made of carbon nano
composite
and water filtration
construction and medicine and i
i mean i'm not going to elaborate more
in this area but if you're interested we
can you can talk to me later how these
uh how narrow technology can impact all
these uh sectors but there are products
today uh in these sectors um
so just
i mean just for another video just for
fun um i'll show you another
boat how powerful it is if it is made of
nano composite now a a lot of boats now
i don't know whether you're familiar
with both or you like bows but so this
is just a demonstration of
the largest object made out of
nano materials basically what it is is
that this boat is primarily carbon
composite
with a few percent of carbon nanotube as
additives
in it
so that with few percent of carbon
nanotubes give you the mechanical
strength
enhancement of 30 percent
so that what does that translate to
economically
now if you have a lighter boat
a stronger boat you use less material
lighter lighter means you use less fuel
so if you run this boat with one tank of
fuel you can go
500 miles
so that's much further than a boat which
is double the weight
and of course speed wise you can go
faster
and since your boat can travel much
longer you can go you can do missions
that is impossible mission impossible
you know when you use a normal boat so
just for for fun um oh maybe i
cannot play here
i don't know why i can't play here
i'll play you a video later
so i just want to zoom in just give you
an example to zoom in i don't know
whether you see properly now
be behind the
coating
of the boat you see this is a typical
carbon fiber composite
now it looks
the same as normal carbon fiber
composite but if you actually look under
the s
you cut the material and you look at the
crux session
and the epoxy
carbon
carbon fiber composite is actually
carbon fiber and epoxy together
and typically the cracks happens in
between in the interface between carbon
fiber and epoxy
so when you add nanotube in the epoxy
basically you disperse nanotube evenly
in the epoxy
the nanotube is it's like glue
very sticky so it sticks much better on
the carbon fiber than without
so then you get a much stronger
composite that's how it works basically
so that basically you know
you have to look at look at the material
under the microscope otherwise you won't
be able to see it microscopically that's
what it looks like um
so here's the sort of figures that you
know very speed 42
knots is a very high speed for a boat
and 150
500 miles uh nautical miles is a very
long range also
so
uh now i don't know whether oh yeah the
video is here
let's see if it please oh this is a very
short one so it's okay it's a military
more monetary
thing
okay
i think i'll stop this too long um i'll
go to china
now this boat is made in usa zydex
is the company right that's the us
company so
the boot yacht is in seattle
so now
i haven't seen we we
we have gone all over all asia we
haven't seen anything like that in asia
so what does that tell you you know the
u.s is still
leading advanced manufacturing i mean if
you look at in in this way
now um
a lot of you if you're in academic you
probably have noticed that china has
published uh you know china has
is known to publish a lot of good papers
you know large number of publication has
grown in the last 10 years very
dramatically and also even patent
you see in nanotechnology you know
pattern number applications also has
increased dramatically
but the quality is a different question
number does not translate into quality
and also doesn't tell you how
commercialization
this commercialization situation
it doesn't really reflect innovation
when you have publication and pattern
um and and if you in fact you know i i
don't know how many of you have visited
universities uh in china i think richard
does a lot of those visits um you know
nowadays i mean compared with 10 years
ago a lot of chinese universities and
chinese canadian sciences
are equipped with state-of-the-art
instruments you go to a lab in beijing
university
it's the same as here you know
nano fabrication facility
characterization for the city anything
you want
um
and you know people busy working no
difference really um but
if you look at the
really tech transfer
not so good in the university
but if you go to chinese canada with
sciences you go to the big sign of
chinese universities
the chinese economic sciences is a big
sign or say institute of chemistry for
example you walk in
you see another sign company
or another company
so chinese security sciences have been a
great incubator for
their spin-offs
but universities in nanotechnology at
least
i'll talk about it or other fields but i
haven't seen many
now if if you have ever worked with
industries in china
chinese industry i you know i walked
into a lot of companies like huawei and
zte all these companies very poor r d um
we you know we try to we have help in
our business on a daily basis we help a
lot of u.s companies try to transfer
their technology to
china manufacturers to for licensing and
so on
it's one of the most challenging thing
for us is that if you don't have a ready
solution ready product it's very
difficult for to work with the chinese
industries
because unlike japanese industries or
korean industries where r d is very
strong if you look at samsung nac
sony all these companies have very
strong r d
they do
everything by themselves they cover the
whole value chain but china like i said
in the beginning
traditionally has been focusing on low
end manufacturing so very poor r d
although
it's starting
but there's a big gap between
the academic publication and industry
adoption
so but but because of the competition
global competition the industries are
looking for differentiation they wanted
to
launch combative products they wanted to
move up the value chain so they need
solutions
enabled by r d
so whether
how do they fill up the gaps
so there are two trends that we have
observed once as i mentioned earlier the
chinese economic sciences are spinning
off companies
and then another very strong emerging
trend is the overseas chinese returnees
who educated could be in stanford
harvard you know anywhere northwestern
cambridge you know in japan somewhere
university of tokyo they go back
attracted by a lot of supported by a lot
of government incentives and set up
companies and we've seen that more and
more now um especially with the funding
so uh uh decreasing difficult and
getting funding in in europe and in us
and and elsewhere you know that's so
another driving factor for those
technopreneurs to go back to china um
well of course it's there are a lot of
incentives for them to go back one is
they're closer to their family the
parents and
and they have fundings from the
government
and also manpower a lot of manpower
there
so
and these are driven by the needs for
solving problems and and also towards
building better cheaper products that's
that's really the goal
there
and we project in the next five to ten
years china will compete in every part
of the value chain in in different
industries and especially in advanced
manufacturing and i will show you
examples later enabled by r d and
nanotech is enabler
so let me just give you an example how
that is happening and
this is real companies that we have
visited and and
in and interacted with in china and so
there's a company
working very actively in led and this
actually a professor he's a very
entrepreneur he's never been overseas
he's based in shanghai and is set up
he's developed a material
for led the phosphor material which is
very important for white light and so in
the past the phosphate
supplier dominated by japanese companies
but today
because chinese domestic suppliers are
much cheaper
it's often it's good enough kind of
performance it doesn't it you don't have
to be the best
good enough and they're taking over that
value chain so traditionally if you see
okay
traditionally chinese
companies are focusing on assembly right
and now they're moving up the value
chain
in the material and wafer
and and similarly
in battery
a lot of you have used lithium-ion
battery
there's a very important additives is
nano-carbon materials
uh provided by shawardenko
and especially those
batteries made in japan i don't know
about the chinese batteries but the
japanese battery has very high
performance ones and and i have this
very secret additives a few percent that
gives you a very long lifetime that's
what i'm using today in my laptop and so
traditionally again it's dominated by
japanese suppliers but now it's taken
over by chinese companies
instead of using this
nano carbon material which is
combination of nanotube and carbon fiber
nano carbon fiber now nanochip only
and i wouldn't mention the name of
company but they they are here
the technology firm come from china and
manufacturing in china but they have an
office here also
so that's how you that's how
that's how we see we analyze the value
chain we look at what what's going on in
this industry and we look at the
upstream the r d investment material and
chinese companies are taking over this
part as well and it's very moving very
rapidly
speed is important i think speed is how
they become successful in the market
now i give you a case study how this is
happening
i want to highlight also the public
partner public private partnership
that actually accelerates
this
what i'm talking about
the taking over of the value chain and
advanced advancing manufacturing so i
want to take an example of the suzhou
industry part i don't know how many of
you are familiar with suzu industry park
this is a very interesting industry park
started by a joint venture between
singapore and suzhou city that was 17
years ago
at that time
suzo wanted to attract fortune 500
basically copy exact copy of singapore
motto singapore model is to attract all
the fortune 500 companies to do
manufacturing not r d manufacturing
after 10 years and i'll continue the
story later but but i wanted to touch
upon the nanotechnology initiative in
that in that area
now
so they started in 90s and now
the industry park executive realized
recognized that nanotechnology is
enabler to advance their
industry to upgrade their industry
very visionary they're thinking ahead
how can we
go forward with our manufacturing we
can't just do low end we have to go
forward
we have to do r d so they recognize nano
is an enabler
what they do is how to build this they
started to build this nano tech
capability what they do is instead of
like
many other industry parks you build
buildings right typical if you're
familiar with china there's a lot of
real estate investment they build
buildings and then hopefully you know to
hope to attract companies to set up
there without any
intelligent design but these guys they
have an intelligent design so instead of
just building buildings they first set
up an institute
they wanted to copy the frankhofer model
from hospital institute
or e3 model in taiwan to build a
institute basically application r d
driven institute which is different from
most of the chinese economic sciences
research institute
which mostly
working on basic research but this is
probably the first i think it's the
first application driven on the
institute
built and nanotechnology focus
with that institute built with the
capability built research facility built
and then they built a incubator called
bio bay
to accommodate companies from overseas
to the returnees to come and set up
companies and also spin off from that
institute
so incubator with that and then three
years ago they even went further
this launched the so-called nanopolis
initiative
to build an entire ecosystem for
nanotechnology
ecosystem meaning you take care of not
only the r d you do build a value chain
you build a service you build the whole
ecosystem that so that the industry can
survive
um which is very intelligent i can tell
you more uh if we have time but let me
just keep moving um
and this this
initiative is a billion dollar
investment which is probably the most
aggressive i think in our uh opinion it
is the most aggressive initiative in
nanotechnology commercialization and
it's very organized
um
now like i said earlier initially they
attract the industry attracts mostly
fortune 500 companies a lot of us
companies are there setting up including
3m
set up their manufacturing
um but
and and but then
with that this is my friend who's a
general manager of biobay she comes here
a lot to attract companies to go there
and i just like to quote her she said
you know from living by a big fish to
raising your own fish a small fish i
mean they
they build this big they attract all
this big company and bio bay is really a
platform to incubate all these you know
uh small fish
and she's extremely successful over six
years
periods right is bio bay a chinese
organization or is it here
chinese okay based in suzhou yeah yeah
it's an incubator okay
she managed to attract 250 companies in
six years okay okay biotech related and
and then partially nanotech but now
nanotech has their own initiative now
three years later she she started this
whole power bay and then
and then nanotech now has spun off into
a ecosystem
in fact the it's very the the nanopus
was launched january this year it's
ready phase one is ready
it's a government-backed organization
and but they
attract a lot not eighty percent of the
ngo bts oversee chinese returning set up
run by oversea chinese returnees
which is a interesting observation um so
to do all that so the the so i want to
come back to the private uh public
private partnership
so so to in order to set all this up
right if
government
the chinese way right top down um put in
a lot of government funding and build
infrastructure the infrastructure what i
mean by that is not just building but
facilities r d facilities pilot
production facilities to allow companies
research institutions to share that
facility with a lower very low cost
to really help the
startups
to lower their costs one of the things
that i find you know the observation
between you know startups in silicon
valley and startups in china is that the
burn rate in china is so low it's
probably ten percent of the burn rate
here i mean i have interacted a lot of
companies here i mean typically a 20
people company here a bun raise a
million dollars between half half a
million to a million dollars for a year
a year yeah sorry no but monthly
with 10 employees with facilities and
everything okay okay yeah
yeah i mean half a million to a million
per month yeah okay absolutely big very
big burn rate in china very minimal 10
that's why it's very easy for them to be
profitable
so this is a i mean i want to highlight
this because the government absorbs a
lot of the cost
like they get free rent
they get
funding
so for r d they get hot they pay half of
the salary which is already low much
lower than here
and and they get the infrastructures
almost very minimal fee
access to the facilities for for very
minimal so that's how you get i mean
that's right the solar i mean how do you
compete in the solar industry same thing
a lot of subsidies from the government
that's why
you know it kills everybody you know
the government that's right well the
government they don't expect the return
for the government is to generate
employment
it's it's very similar singapore does
the same thing right when multinational
when 3m comes in
to singapore or china
they give them like 50
subsidy for all the entire operation
cost
and what they get back is employment
they employ 3m employee
and a lot of people in both places
and then of course the tax
at the end
who will
own
uh intellectual property the company
company yes
yeah and and if you file a patent they
give you also bonus as well the
government that's why they buy a lot of
crap patterns
is this any pattern so yeah i don't
think the petals pattern final flat also
has been subsidized by the government
that's right but how come the pilot
plant would be generic because each of
the companies would have different needs
of pilots
right so i'll give you an example i'm
actually going to go to that later but
um so they built this um in the
nanopolis they built this six-inch mems
pilot plan this is tens of millions of
dollars investment of course they buy
equipment second hand to lower the cost
um so this pilot plan is available for
industry and the research institution to
come and use it and they still have to
figure out how to manage this this is
brand new okay this is just set up it's
going to be ready up and running
sometime end of this year
in terms of how this is going to operate
to be you know self-sustained i think
they're still working on it they're
hiring they're hiring managers to try to
do that so anyone want a job
go there
um
so so the foundation the public private
partnership government put in a lot of
support um and and coupled with the
entrepreneurship of the chinese
technopreneurs uh scientists and with
the high speed of the speed
is really critical in china we are
impressed with the speed absolutely and
then you know investment and
and with the talent you need people to
do the work a lot of i mean looks like
they've been very successful in
attracting talents
the chinese government and they're very
aggressively recruiting everybody
and then they targeted the market
chinese market i mean i have colleagues
in singapore went to china and set up
companies
and this is a idea for them because they
can't do anything in singapore because
no market there
and
incentive for spin-off is not that good
it's difficult to raise money so to go
to china this
basically the consequence of that for
foreign companies that if they take over
a domestic market is difficult for
multinationals to operate so that's
that's
a
alarm for
foreign companies
and then of course eventually now i'm
personally i'm also seeing chinese
companies is trying to go global
i mean different from japanese companies
i spend a lot of time in japan and i
think
there's a very big difference between
the chinese companies and japanese
companies a lot of japanese companies
especially small ones
are very domestic focus because japan
already have a big market right more
than 100 million people but the chinese
they have a billion dollar billion
people market billion people market yeah
and
they want to go global from day one i
mean it's a different mindset
uh
so but yeah like i said earlier you know
the public private partnership playing a
very important role in accelerating the
commercialization of nanotechnology in
china and with the the government
support building up
ecosystem and infrastructure and it's
very organized i mean as a top-down way
manner if you compare with other
countries
in asia
it's very organized um and
to so further look at how this is done i
mentioned earlier this is 1.5 billion
investment of nanopolis i mentioned
earlier
and and they prepared the ecosystem
value chain now when i talk about what i
mentioned organized
let me tell you how organized so in in
this nanotech apparently can do many
things right so you have to look at the
industry sector let's look at led if you
look at
solar you look at um
light well light lighting lighting
lighting is one and solar and then
um
mems
mems for sensors and that's anothers so
they look they will identify what
makes sense what industry makes sense
and then they look at what capability
they have remember i mentioned the the
institute that they set up and the early
the van gogh type of institute they set
up
so they is the regional government yeah
this industry people who are in charge
of this
industry yeah okay so the is the
executive the management
organization
so when they have this institute they
already build up the capability
technical capability for example battery
they have a battery pilot plant they
have solar they have the the scaling
nitride this power electronics scaling
mitral platform so they already have all
this platform and they look at with this
platform what i can build in terms of
industry value chain and what's missing
in in the industry part and then
and then very organically they engage
companies or talents or capabilities to
fill in the gap to complete that value
chain
and then
and complete the ecosystem so that's how
organized they are
i mean i'm i'm really like
impressed i mean i haven't seen anyone
you know organize industry but in this
way and emerging technology um and of
course you do you you cover you know the
path to market is you do you start from
you know technology idea you support the
research development prototyping mass
production so you can do all that they
want they want the companies to be able
to do all this within the park
now from in terms of our co-financing
i've talked about financing before the
entrepreneurs can get money now
in case you're interested
basically it's a sort of if they say
okay richard you want to go and set up a
company they will say okay we
give you in kind so in total 10 million
rmb is like 1.6 million u.s dollars
you're pretty much committed you come
but you have to first set up a company
and commit a million rmb first as a set
of companies so capital you put in the
capital and then you get the grants like
free lab office rental and and housing
you can literally live there for free
when you go there you don't have to
worry about those costs so so for a lot
of the technopreneurs going back they
actually go back
mainly male
in their 40s
and 50s and they leave the family behind
in silicon valley or in you know new
york somewhere you know they go back
adventure you know a lot of they have a
lot of fun uh back in suzhou over there
oh this was just one example but uh is
that a special thing for returnees or is
it a special thing for anything for
attorneys and for uh
if you can manage the chinese language
you can go there too okay okay but you
have to have a technology you have to
have that sure idea a proposal yeah yeah
but
really somebody who is not a returnee
right not originally from china or
family from china
it's also accessible yes the language
issue is the issue oh and language is an
issue
you have to write the proposal in
chinese okay which is a problem
but if you can hire somebody to do that
yeah okay okay
we don't provide that service
so i mentioned earlier um so anyway it's
pretty attractive it's it's basically
make you very easy like you can go there
live for free
leave your family behind and you can
just do just focus on your innovation
and work on the product right that's all
you need to worry about
and
to make things happen what what
they want to make things happen no what
happens if they fail what happens if
they don't jump
back to the us
are they required to give back the money
okay unless it's okay i didn't mention
there's a there's a financing there's a
grant that given by the government which
doesn't require any
uh no equity no nothing
but there's uh another part that it's
like five million i think 5.3 million
it's supported by the vc it's equity
so
well you can claim bankruptcies
that's what they do now this is for the
fields that the government has decided
on right
um they have any kind of business no
they have a strategic areas for example
okay water right water is a good
technology right if you have anything
with water
that makes sense an environment you know
clean up the air water um of course
anything on mams anything on lighting
okay solar things that they think is
important
for them
yeah okay not okay not quantum computing
yeah sure but
you know one of the things is they're
aiming at having
full supply chains inside the park yeah
they want everything from the first
components and materials all the way
into final assembly kind of in the park
right
sounds like they're creating japanese
business groups
i think they're
they're very also they try to work with
international bodies as well yeah so
they try to create international
alliances with japan with korea
but but the thing of having a supply
chain that is
rel you know independent companies but
yet all in the same area and all kind of
depending on the same value chain
right is but that's okay that's
it's not there yet yeah it's being built
okay okay so it's in the process okay
maybe five years down the road you you
see pretty good but in led it's pretty
comprehensive now the reason i mention
that is because
the different kind of profit margins the
component business is an ugly business
after a while
because there will always be some place
cheaper you can do manufacturing
right
and advanced manufacturing is great for
a while while that window is open but
then somebody else learns how to do the
same advanced manufacturing
yeah so
how do you build this up into a
sustainable thing where they're
continuing to innovate
that's yet to be observed yeah this is
the next problem yeah yeah but what what
they're trying to do like i was watching
the led industry value chain they're
pretty comprehensive now they have the
wafer guys
they have the packaging they have the
material people and you know the market
as well so
i mean keep in mind that you know every
chinese region is like a country in
europe it's big you know if you look at
the region this suzhou region they have
the regions already 20 million people
i mean the whole jiangsu province is 100
million people i mean that's inside this
is a city one of the major cities in the
province
yeah so the market is attractive
um so i mentioned earlier the chinese
chemical sciences have a very flexible
spin-off
mechanism so they allow you to part your
company on site
and it's amazing they like
because the institute owns your company
so
you you can do everything so i see in
fact a lot of things
there's a strong incentive to spin off
companies constantly in fact every month
you know i see it like every month there
a new company is being set up
nanotech companies what happens is that
it's also a way to get more funding
because if you spin off a company you
can get additional funding other than
your r d funding like at the institute
you can get the funding for the company
so that's why you can get
you know the funding for the company and
the institute and they both pay for the
same people
so
you know they have no conflict there's
no conflict of interest
because the institute owns those
companies
and they just get company from another
government organization either central
government or
um
regional government and vcs
so you get basically it's a way to
capture as much capital as possible
for for the r d and they can use the
labs they can you know have the same
people doing
doing both research and
for the company product development
so a lot of very flexible mechanisms
that doesn't work here well it works
there
and of course the government-backed vcs
i mentioned earlier that will take
equity of do you mind if i ask a
question at this point
so i've also seen the same kind of
things with universities in china right
universities can own startup companies
that spun out of the university research
do they think about an exit
when they create the company i mean is
there a point of time when the
university or the
chinese academy of sciences would sell
all their stock in the company and get
out of it and do something different
let me give you one example this
company i'm going to actually one of my
case studies okay
and it's already ipo okay suzhou
university the university actually
it's a one of the major
uh shareholder
i think the university x exited okay
when they go ipo
so
it's just i mean such a big country
everything is possible over there
another quote like uh from this company
that moved from shanghai to suzhou i
think but but we'll talk about ecosystem
i mentioned ecosystem just a little bit
more uh detail on on the ecosystem so
of course now i mentioned earlier the r
d platforms
let's set up this institute provide the
r d platforms capabilities
that's very that's that's really
very important differentiate this
industry apart from the many other
industry parks
this is really critical for the
ecosystem and then and then of course
you engage industry partners already in
the industry park or outside the
industry park and and you attract the
talent
and and then you
do the startup and then also the
investors and and and fund and fundings
so this is how they see as an ecosystem
um over there and
and and talk about talents so this is
really
important for for this whole ecosystem
talent
people without people you can't make
anything you can't make anything happen
um not not buildings so these are the
people who come a lot of them coming
from overseas they are really well top
technical experts uh with venture
experience with global business
experience could be somebody from dow
here go back you know could be from you
know 3m to go back there and do
something and i've i've i visited a
company actually used to work for one of
the multinationals
not that one of the camera companies in
the us
dupont yeah so they left
they left the company and
started their own company i don't know
what they do with the ip
right so that's why they keep a very low
profile
no websites the company has no website
very typical okay so
and like as i mentioned earlier 80 of
the over 200 companies of bio base are
established by foreign talents
so
so this is a quote from my my um
my senior consultant actually he
prepared a presentation for me
he is australian i mean he lived in
japan for 20 years flown in japanese so
he you know helped me in china every
time he goes there he's just it's crazy
this place is just
amazing i mean he lived in japan worked
in physicists for 15 years he knows very
well the japanese corporate culture and
everything you see similarities in the
engineer and the engineers the passion
for innovation and and and developing
new products but the difference is that
the chinese engineers are entrepreneur
they go to the market
faster they are interested in going to
the market rather than just focusing
staying in
innovating uh product
so
so that's his quote
um so today
in fact there are in our statistics
there are 50 nanotech companies in that
park within the last few years but 200
related companies
that's official figure is 200 but
my objective assessment is only 50 but
others are kind of nano related not
really nano
i'll give you some case studies later um
so just to for you to sort of take home
with like key messages about the
entrepreneurs in in that region
so
the key to success are the engineers
scientists and entrepreneurs on the
ground um
and they're just going for it very
pragmatic down-to-earth attitude can do
you know want to advance no fear very
optimistic they're optimistic this is
amazing the optimism of those guys
is just amazing they think that anything
is possible they'll make it happen
um
and okay this is so compared with
singapore since i'm based in singapore
and i you know i would like to compare
because singapore japan and taiwan and
all different places and and let's just
look at singapore now singapore if some
of you are familiar with singapore i
think will pay a lot of people to go
let's go there yeah they confirm you
know multinational big companies
uh universities
um you know mit has a center there you
know cambridge
singapore for the brand basically brand
is important they wouldn't go for some
universities not prominent they go for
prominent universities and and they pay
them to go there it doesn't matter what
the outcome is really they just want to
look good but the chinese
they want substance they want you to
actually deliver
i mean that's a very different um very
different attitude
yeah and yeah this is what i
um
so that's i think that's pretty much it
and i'll go to the case studies now
yeah oh one one thing about
the value chain
now what i see in a lot of industries
today they say solar
in the solar industry equipment the the
equipment is still pretty much foreign
it's important
equipment and and also led
like the mocvd systems are made in japan
or germany or even u.s
so the equipment part china has not
been very
good
in terms of machinery
it takes longer time to build that
capability and japan is still very
dominant japan german germany the two
countries are very dominant in the in
the machine equipment business so
they've been doing very very well um
that's why
yeah
german
germany's economy is doing extremely
well with they're all the you know
export in their um
equipment
but things are changing
in china
i mean some at least we have the
companies that we visited like in the
area of um
like led especially now they're they're
starting to develop their own equipment
and different their own proprietary
processes so that's emerging but it's
not a very strong capability yet but you
see that you know different a small
student you know smes doing that yet um
not not a big trend yet but it's
emerging so something to keep in mind so
if you're in the equipment business
hurry up you know before they
they will not be buying your equipment
very soon um
so on vcs
a lot of vcs in china is just
overwhelming number of
vcs basically financing is not a problem
over there if you have good idea
no problem getting funding funding is
not a problem and market is not a
problem it's about getting the business
done
getting to the market but of course when
we look at all these companies
um now the ones that i picked are very
very good but the ones that are spinning
off now i think half of them are rubbish
so it's not going to die very soon
because again it's the this this trend
of because of getting more money trying
to get more money just to spin off
company just for the sake of getting
more money that's not good that's not
sustainable
uh intellectual property i think a lot
of people are wrong about that now um
there's no absolute protection anywhere
um
and this is we'll have to face the fact
i mean there's a fact this is life okay
we can't protect intellectual property
um now suzhou on the other hand is kind
of rather safe
uh compared with the rest of china
because they have very strong ip
protection and prosecution
practice
and but
in practice is hire people you trust be
very selective and treat them well and
retain them and
and if you still don't feel confident
keep your core ip outside of china so
that's how you do it
but at the end i mean the
the chinese company may not license ip
from you most of the time they prefer
not to unless it's absolutely necessary
but they take ideas from you and they do
it on them by themselves
i mean i think japan same thing i mean
in in in in this way um
and
and often the solution is good enough
you know in china is a good enough
solution is is okay to enter the chinese
market
let me give you a few case studies on
you know
a few three companies that i or four
companies that i i picked
are doing pretty good um so our first
one is a very early stage company very
very young company the guy professor xi
and he's a full-time employee of the
chinese educational sciences okay and
he's educated in japan
i think he worked in sony briefly and
so his core technology is gallium
nitride
he grow gallium nitride in a very
low-cost way
so he basically used the institute as
his uh his companies inside institute he
has you know six
machines grow the uh two inch now two
and four inch
um gallium nitride of course what does i
don't know whether you're familiar with
a nitride again it's a very it's an
emerging three five material for power
electronics for future and led lighting
right
so it's a very emerging very hot
materials now for um
and and of course low to be able to
produce this material low cost
it's critical for the market adoption of
this material um
it's for lasers in fact
they make together with their partner
you see that big projectors over there
so big this projector lcd projector
they make in china now is a small a
little bit bigger than this
projector portable
i actually have one copy i asked them to
give me a sample so i i didn't carry it
with news i have one over to me but um
so that portable projector
that's um using the the light one of the
lasers or the light source is gallium
nitride
so they make this kind of products now
in china
so again the guy i mean it's very early
stage they are not they are kind of
almost break even
so
these people who are making gallium
nitride wafers right
have started making the projector itself
what would the company oh they work with
the projectile okay okay so they provide
the weight okay okay yeah
but they are looking at not just wafer
they want to also move up the velocity
they want to make
power electronic devices as well
so and this is primarily now focusing
the chinese market but again the whole
company is being incubated
in the chinese chemical sciences and
they have revenue enough for for them to
almost break even which is totally
impossible if you have any company
outside of china because like i said
earlier all the
in-kind
support that they get
another company called nanomicro the guy
professor dr jiang and he's actually
educated in the u.s
i mean he has an interesting story he
worked in u.s companies he left and went
back to china because he felt that u.s
companies are very short-term driven
he couldn't do things that would take
longer than five years in the u.s so he
went back
and he could do whatever he wanted and
he developed
this
silica sphere
they can control the size you know range
of different range of sizes and they
sell them now to chinese to us companies
now
i mean he's now he's just you know
entered the us market last year he went
for a show here and then
and in the uh previously he had the
prime
his primary customers are japanese
companies lcd uh makers and also
pharmaceutical companies in china
um so it's interesting and he's
profitable this guy
five years free rent
and you know 100 people
already profitable you know
but interesting u.s he thinks that u.s
is much more short-term driven that's
why he couldn't stay here you go back to
china he can do long-term development so
he's got about 100 employees in the
company
do you know how many of them are
technical and how many are sales
majority technical
okay
engineers
so
sales not not so much they're not see
one thing about the chinese startups is
that they're not so good at sales the
marketing their marketing is not that
good
um not normally like this this guy i
mean he's
he's not maybe well if you've got
yeah
yes they don't in fact they don't need
because the chinese market is at the
back door they don't have to do
aggressive marketing but they do realize
that they are lacking global marketing
so they're trying to
figure out what to do they probably
maybe you know american trained
marketing people can get a job there
yeah that's one prime opportunity for
you guys
this is one of my favorite companies
tanyan um you know the the phone that
you have in fact again samsung phone
samsung
is one of one of the most innovative
company in terms of smartphone in your
samsung's galaxy the
heatsink material
traditionally has been
you people use copper as hissing
material no more copper now
this carbon
uh graphite it's a graphite material
so this is i mean i i i have a few
slides about
nano carbon material graphene 902
graphite it's great material because it
has
great conductivity electrically and
thermally it's great mechanical strength
it's just if you make stuff out of this
material it's multifunctional you get
high you know very high mechanical
strength very
flexible and strong at the same time
electrically conductive
and thermally conductive i mean the
conductivity of this material
it's three times of that of copper
that's why samsung work with them and
and they supply this thing uh to
something and
the amazing thing is this guy this
company is only two years old
profitable
20 million dollar sales
100 people
this is an amazing story and this guy is
uh professor dr
mr she actually is a master degree an
engineer and he never when he never got
education in overseas he's just
homegrown technopreneur amazing doesn't
speak english
a son emails him in chinese never reply
i mean english never replies i have to
get my assistant to write chinese and
that's how
i can communicate with him
um amazing company this is one of my you
know favorite uh entrepreneurs in china
and then this one this one is an intro
very interesting 10 years old 10 years
company last year when ipo in the
shenzhen stock market now a few hundred
now i think they have grown to 500
people
initially the first five years they
literally lived inside a university
like probably like no revenue when they
started to have revenue then they moved
out and
now this coming one one of the
one i'm most impressed by this company
is that they cover the whole value chain
they make their own equipment
they do their own
patterning
so what it is is that
you know you know the um let me think of
an example think of lotus leaf self
cleaning
structure structural
function
think of lotus leaves is self cleaning
super hydrophobic
water droplets go down it doesn't you
know bring it down dirt with it never
gets dirty
so imagine you make the surface you
mimic that surface
on a film
and put it on your table
it's like lotus leaves
so in the past people do coding
uh to do you know functional coding on
your on on surface these guys no coding
make structure
and how do you make make this structure
how do you make it in large volume you
do roll the roll nano imprint
so what how you do is you make the mold
with the structure so using
optical
beam lithography optical lithography and
you make them more and you stamp and
print that's nano imprint stamp print
and then to do to go
mass production you do roto roll
so that's that's a
i mean
when i track nano imprint technology for
a long time but these guys come up with
road roll and come up and have the
product in the market like two years ago
already amazing i mean
and now they already have products in
the in chinese market like chinese
identity cards they make all these all
these
structures that they make
it's now replacing a lot of the
materials that that um that's being used
and lower costs
so so uh the key to success of these
people is that you know better better
and lower costs
that's how they
can take over the market
and they're profitable obviously i think
their market cap is uh 300 million
dollars
in in that stock market right now
so yeah that i think that's all for me
yeah we've got some time for questions
lauren thanks very much
so i think the the question that's
really kind of burning for me
is what does this mean for us
i mean
do we have opportunities you mentioned
that supplying equipment's an
opportunity now
is this going to open up new
opportunities for the high-tech
community outside
china i think one of the things that
the chinese um like industry park for
example let's get down to this
industrial park for example they
wouldn't need very much because to start
everything from scratch takes time you
know the chinese like the speed they
want to
they want to make things very fast so
they would be interested in licensing
uh or bring in whatever ips develop
likes in the valley
and and develop the product and enter
the market in china i think that's
something that the the industry would be
very interested in is to have
you know to have some sort of joint
venture or some sort of partnership with
entrepreneurs here or companies here
who's interested in entering the chinese
market for example if you if you have
any technology that can give
high fun better functionality for a
smartphone made in china they will be
interested right or or solar cells or or
lighting
and anything that they make today they
have very industry manufacturing
capability and you have something that
it's they need we we went i mean i
represented one of my portfolio
companies we went to zte
we want to sell our transparent
conductive films to them or these guys
of course they don't have very strong
r d so they said okay we like your
material but can you make the module
the touchscreen module so we can just
plug in yeah or we introduce our
supplier
our module supply you can integrate your
films right so so i think if um the
chinese they will make stuff by
themselves in any in any case
whatever i mean
to make those stuff actually that's kind
of the question is is this going to lead
to greater isolation as opposed to
greater globalization they've got a big
market they've got their own sources of
venture capital they've got government
support do they really need the outside
this is a very good question politically
um i think
um
if you if you just isolate china i think
they can do everything by themselves
if they you put them on the moon
do you think they will yeah they will go
to the moon no no do you think they will
isolate themselves they will not they
will not but but i'm just saying
hypothetically if you put if you isolate
china they can do they literally can do
everything by themselves well i mean
there's not many markets that are big
enough to develop their own technology
standards and not worry about global
standards
you know that that's a direct
thing coming off of that yeah i don't
want to monopolize too much of the time
i saw your hand yes
so
thank you for sharing this uh those news
and
those successful case is really
impressive but here i want to um
ask for your opinion on the failing case
which is sound type solar
synthetic power
you know that companies actually we see
which is like right next to us yeah
i know those guys
yeah i just want your
comment on that case because uh like
years ago that's what uh that company
was the largest manufacturer for solar
panels in the world and suddenly
announces bankruptcy and you know years
ago it was regarded as the icon of
chinese high-tech company now is a
sinking boat so people people are
arguing whether it's a special case or
is a typical
chinese
chinese you know company that cannot
cannot really be sustainable so what's
your opinion well this is a very
complicated case uh first of all
well there's a very bad culture in china
in terms of a high-tech industry
when suntec power set up it was the only
solar company
but then when it became successful
everybody set up a solar factory
literally you know one of the company my
friend worked in assault the guy sells
soy sauce i mean he make a fortune
selling soy sauce and they set up a
solar factory of course has to shut down
the company at some point
but you know just you know it's like
everybody does the same bloody thing and
and then they flood the market with
cheap product because they can't
it's just it's over supply they just
tend to create this oversupply
of products
it's
really the bad thing about the culture i
mean they don't have they don't respect
um
i mean i always use this example of
italian uh cheese you know like if you
eat mozzarella mozzarella
it's only made the good mozzarella is
only made in napoli you know southern
italy and no one else make the same
thing but in china if you if you're six
if you know that haircut company's a
haircut shop is doing well everyone else
around you will set up a haircut shop
just that's how it works is it you know
this is the thing
sorry
that because will that ecosystem sustain
itself
you know because you have this kind of
competition it does not because when you
when you when you do this when everybody
does the same thing and complete each
other it's just not sustainable and you
have oversupply of everything i also
that raises a question to me
the managers of the science parks
do they start to all think the same way
in terms of selecting particular types
of companies or particular business
lines of companies
actually now the science box are getting
more smarter for example like suzhou
will pick areas that
they have a differentiation so they'll
look at like wushi and other places
she does those um uh small sensors or
they don't do that bushi has this of um
there's another they do a big thing in
maps but they they want to differentiate
from which they build the foundry only
doing certain things and and nanjing
doing like biotech you know so they so
they they try to differentiate
themselves now the original government
they're getting smarter but the solar
thing and led same thing over supply
right over supply now the oversupply
there's another problem this is just one
one part of the problem now the solar
cell
sun tech and many other solar companies
was having a lot of
sales is because
they export to europe primarily when
europe markets slowed down
everybody suffered
um
so they depend they are dependent on
foreign market export well internally
they don't consume they haven't consumed
very much solar cell now of course the
government try to invest more and build
solar farms and but that takes time
right so they had this gap of completely
dependent on foreign
consumer
and not really
internally consume the solar panel
and then and then the government quickly
tried to launch a policy but the
adoption the implementation of the
policy of building the farm
this is this gap so i'm still you know
robust but i'm still optimistic about
solar but it's just you know too bad
then the last year this year next year
is not going to be good
sorry so just go ahead and show it yeah
so just to clarify so you think
soundtech's more of a special cases like
wow
you can you can read a lot of stuff from
sun tech the whole case it's too
complicated but a lot more sun tech oh
yeah
oh absolutely okay a lot of people are
feeling go ahead oh it's not a special
case
it also be
in addition to culture also barrier to
entry yeah really because as you know to
make waiver
you know the solar effect waiver is
pretty simple everybody can do it right
right but it's within a certain range
right right i mean efficiency of what
two percent or so right yeah right but
the products that you're talking about
the examples you gave us the four or
five companies you highlighted
they have barrier to entry that probably
they have a very good differentiation oh
yeah like the the tangent well it's just
very difficult
film yeah
that's very unique so
that's niche that's really niche i mean
that's why i the stuff that i picked are
really innovative the the technology
have you know you can't just copy
um those guys i mean i mean for example
like okay
to to look further i mean my most
favorite company is the the the wifi
company because i think they're gonna be
very sustainable the other company i'm
not sure because they enjoy too much
government support
tanyan the
e carbon actually his english name is e
carbon e-carbon
very much 20 million revenue right first
year
and
i i see this company really sustainable
because they they don't get all this
benefit from like other companies like
this i like all the other companies i
mentioned they all get all the free rent
subsidy manpower subsidy everything so
those are great conditions do you think
the science parks are going to be
essential for high-tech companies you
really have to be in a science park if
you're going to be serious in china or
will there be other ways to get into the
market outside the high-tech parks
there's nowhere else to park your
company to build this science box where
you can
you can you can have your company at
home but they don't do that
science fair is just easy it's easy
infrastructure for you to access to
services
what happens if you start to get turned
down by one science part are there
people who try going from one to the
next oh they do yeah like some shanghai
company will move to suzhou or vice
versa yeah
they move around
one more go ahead
the science park uh that you have seen
in suzhou in china
to the taiwanese uh science park as you
know they play a very big part in taiwan
yeah like for example like shinzo right
um well sincho it's very i mean again
it's a very successful
and um
already especially in the electronic
industry uh but the suzhou one is more
it's beyond electronics they already
have certain electronics uh but not in
the scale of taiwan
they're building
materials
um
i think you know
i think taiwan is already doing well but
at the same time the the
the way i see this particular case of
building this ecosystem and building
nanotechnology enable
ecosystem i think it's very unique
um
it's it's it's the entire thing is so
organic very very organized
different from other taiwan or other
industry parks let me ask one more
question and then we're going to have to
break and have refreshments yeah the
last question uh so
five ten years from now are we going to
see china's version of intel are we
going to see a real world leader coming
out of this or is it going to be a good
system that's very good inside china but
are we going to see the next dental
coming out of this
why not
um i don't see china is going to build
like huawei the kind of
company will
i don't see huawei is very innovative i
mean in terms of i mean they're already
big yeah they're big but they're
big doesn't mean that they're very
innovative
well
um i don't see i i think china will be
had we'll have a lot of smes a strong
sme
in terms of the emerging technology
okay but it's not going to be intel ibm
it's different
okay but the the companies like huawei
zte these are
companies that growing
pretty big but
they are not focusing on a lot they're
not spending a lot in r d the way what
i've seen in japan and the u.s and korea
i think they just have no patience to do
that and then i think the dominant
phenomena will be the smes what i
mentioned these companies that that i
mentioned these companies going to grow
and thrive
okay i think
right culture how those specimens could
be sustainable over the longer period
particularly the highest nano technology
companies i forgot to mention is
this is increasing respect for ip
because those entrepreneurs
they they they depend on them they
depend on ip they need to they protect
their own ip they also respect ip
so the culture will change in china but
like i said i mean no guarantee of
protection because china is very big and
you protect your ip in this park you go
to another part you it's very difficult
to suit those guys
let's actually walter let's take it
offline we're running overtime and i'm
not supposed to do that for stanford so
thanks very much dr lew and we'll talk
more over coffee
you